welcome back to CBS this morning how
about some news on getting back to work
as more states work to reopen knowing
who has the coronavirus is going to be
key and one way to do that it was
something called contact tracing that's
about tracking down anyone who may have
come into contact with a person who has
tested positive New York City for
example says it plans to hire a thousand
people to help with that effort by the
end of the month
nationally experts say it will take an
army of people asking all the right
questions I traveled to Connecticut to
find out how contact tracing works hello
my name is Melissa I'm calling on behalf
of the New Haven Health Department every
day Yoriko mid-nineteen test result was
positive people like Melissa Thomas are
chasing some of America's newest cases
of the corona virus their mission is to
break the chain of infection by
developing a list of everyone who may
have been significantly exposed to a
patient than urging those close contacts
to monitor symptoms and self quarantine
I'm really looking for any time from
that Wednesday until now if you've had
prolonged contact with anyone outside of
your house and while this call was only
a demonstration my colleague from work
come over Thomas says she can usually
reach about 60% of the patients she
tries getting all the information she
needs in less than 30 minutes I think
the hardest part is getting the people
to answer the phone in the first place
for those that we actually reach out and
talk to whether they answer the phone or
call us back they're very willing to
help contact tracing is proven to help
control diseases like Ebola and SARS and
as of now it also seems to be working
for the New Haven Department of Public
Health in Connecticut where Thomas is a
volunteer so at your very best rate as
quickly as you can go you're going
through two calls per hour with people
picking up we're doing between 2 to 3 an
hour 2 to 3 now is that quick enough to
make the case count go down on the
computer so in New Haven we've averaged
about a hundred new cases a day and with
our team we're able to handle that well
there's no federal requirement for
contact tracing leaving states and
cities to create plans
the room I think it's important for us
to come up with a strategy that says
we're not just gonna try and mitigate
the disaster we're actually gonna try
and contain the growth of the virus this
is an opportunity to go out find the
embers and stomp them out before they
become a wildfire exactly right
Massachusetts governor Charlie Baker
announced the first statewide contact
tracing program last month it's grown
into a thousand person team reaching
hundreds of patients a day people want
to talk about what it means to have this
virus they're looking for help with
respect to how they isolate and they're
willing to give us their close contacts
which by the way so far have not been
big numbers but those numbers are likely
to spike as people return to work and to
stay ahead of the pandemic America will
need an additional 100,000 contact
tracers according to Johns Hopkins
University by one count states have
hired or announced plans to hire about
66,000 so far as the lack of a federal
standard point your state at risk and
surrounding states at risk I certainly
think if the feds were to participate if
the feds were to establish as you say
national standards or or some rules
around compatibility with respect in one
state to another because you're right
there is a lot of back-and-forth between
states and people move I mean they don't
just work they move I think that could
be very helpful as more Americans test
positive for the virus
researchers say confidentiality is key
for contact tracing that means shielding
the identity of every kovat positive
patient even from the people they may
have infected contact tracing is
critical virtually nobody disagrees with
that but out there in the public there
is a concern that the more that the
government even if it's the health
department is prying into people's lives
and movements the less privacy we'll
have as Americans how do you balance the
public health mission with the privacy
concerns of citizens I would say we take
confidentiality very seriously that's a
big component of what we do as far as
not sharing information of who is a
positive test results that is extremely
important but also by notifying people
that they may have been accept
it greatly reduces the spread of the
disease so the more information people
can provide the better and the more
effective that this technique will be
and speaking of the future technology is
also expected to play a really big role
in this effort Google and Apple later
this month are expected to debut a tool
and app allowing people to receive an
automatic alert if their phone has been
near another phone of a person who is
kovat positive but for many people that
brings up big privacy concerns Gayle and
in fact the recent poll found that more
than half of Americans even if such an
app existed would not be willing to use
it at least so far we're of course gonna
be covering that as the technology
begins to roll out but contact tracing
it's a term we've heard a little bit
we're gonna hear it a whole lot through
May and into the summer I'm sure of that
Gayle well what Wow Tony I can't wait
for that tool from from Google and Apple
I will certainly be the first one I
always think people have nothing to hide
hide nothing I know privacy is very
important here I also think that
knowledge and information or power and
the more knowledge and information we
have the better off we are
seems like we just have to get people to
answer the phone it's tough yeah that's
true Gayle that's definitely true I mean
another one of the questions is if
you've come into contact with somebody
and you have to isolate at home how do
you make money how do you how do you
make a living one of the interesting
proposals from president Trump's former
FDA Commissioner Scott Gottlieb he's
leading a group that wants 30 billion
from Congress to help pay people if
their contact traced to stay home and
and be safe 30 billion a lot of money
could go a long way